jean pierre blackburn à saguenay yvon
godin a battu hull chila cops qui
viendra dans quelques secondes à ottawa
et pierre paquette à montréal bonsoir
soir d'avril gossement soir les choses
changent
depuis qu'on s'est parlé la dernière
fois monsieur gaudet qu'est ce qui se
passe avec le npd selon vous c'est quoi
votre analyse
la première manche harper est un un os
de sa de pouvoir aller toucher les
points sensibles la terreur faire peur
aux gens où aller du côté des émotions
ce pour pouvoir bien qu'il faut venir
quelqu'un du strady pour le faire pour
cacher le vraiment la livrée chose
regarde à l'économie regardèrent a
acquis ce que c'est que les canadiens
pour choisir un premier ministre
c'est qui qui est capable de voir est
capable de mener le pays il y a fait
sobre mais moi je pense avoir être
temporaire des gens va s'apercevoir que
ça aucun sens de choisir un premier
ministre jeu sur un élément qui est ce
qui va arriver je pense qu'il ya eu un
recul de faire mais moi j'en crois
vraiment confiance qu'avec la les
semaines à venir le vrai sondage voir et
des 19 octobre il va falloir mieux il va
falloir que monsieur mulcair présente
plus fort sans argent dos à sa
plateforme puis je pense qu'il va
convaincre les canadiens que on est
l'anti peu déplacé à stephen harper qui
représentait les canadiens public
québécois dans votre tête mais ce godet
mais je sens quand même une légère
inquiétude la soie soyons honnêtes mais
je veux dire écoutez moi je me rappelle
que quand les conservateurs étaient bas
dans les sondages voyez pas monsieur
blackburn rire quand les libéraux
étaient bas dans les sondages voyaient
pas madame encore rien fait si vous
voulez que je reçoive pas commencé en
mai
c'est normal mais monsieur normal je
pense que quand et où descendent
d'argent dit toujours que le vrai
sondage voir d'élections mais quand tu
bd sandage ces problèmes mais je pense
que c est là que ça ça dix autres
écoutez si vous voulez gagner ces temps
que la barque est dans la rue vous allez
frapper aux portes
vous travaillez fort alors c'est ça
qu'il va falloir qu'ils se posent des
prochains jo semaine très bien monsieur
monsieur blackburn
ça vaut mieux que ça a l'air c'est une
évidence
c'est sûr que c'est une nouvelle
dynamique qui est en train de
s'installer comme vous comme on le voit
il ya une chute de 18 points en deux
semaines pour le nouveau parti
démocratique au québec ce qui est énorme
comme chute dans les sondages alors
maintenant on arrive comme dans une
situation où ses scores
le parti libéral du canada et le parti
conservateur qui seront probablement les
deux parties qui seront à l'avant plan
au cours des 15 prochains jours
maintenant attention il n'y a rien
d'acquis il ya un débat ce soir c'est un
débat face à face face à face ça veut
dire que vous êtes l'un devant l'autre
et vous devez parler plus longuement
vous devez parler en profondeur de votre
programme électoral et aussi on peut
s'attendre à ce que certaines attaques
sur le programme électoral de l'un ou
l'autre
alors comment tout ça va se jouer ce
soir c'est cet important et est ce que
monsieur mal caire pour arriver
admettons avec une annonce que tout le
monde dirait war pour faire pour
modifier un peu tous sont là l'histoire
du nikkei recule avant l'heure des
canadiens là dessus alors on verra bien
nos panélistes disait ça va prendre un
coup de circuit
chantal hébert et celle ci au juste ça
prendrait un coup de circuit
au npd donc à monsieur mulcair ce soit
celle à copse votre chef
lors d'une autre débaucher nous en
français et beaucoup de gens qui avaient
du sang pas de sa cassette le faudrait
qu'il soit plus authentique vous
attendez à quoi ce soir vous de monsieur
trudeau mais je pense que dans le
premier débat en français ce qui est
intéressant c'est que pas à travers le
canada il était sorti comme le gagnante
alors c'est ce qu' ils étaient
authentiques dont les dossiers je pense
que si on veut voir quand monsieur
rocard a commencé à perdre des pédales
un petit peu je pense que c'est quand
même ce trou d'eau a dit que nous on les
libéraux vont accepter d'avoir des
déficits pour investir dans
l'infrastructure de l'économie et ça
s'est vraiment démarqué la différence
parce que le parti conservateur et le
parti néo démocrates ont pris le même
politique sur l'économie alors que le
parti libéral était plus vite et plus
plus courageuse dans les investissements
qui devront avoir lieu
ceci dit je pense ce soir pour lui c'est
la question de continuer la force et
aussi je pense de s'exprimer aux
québécois et aux québécoises comme un
des leurs si tu vois par exemple le don
de parler plus plus franchement d'une
certaine façon le parler mais je trouve
qu'ils parlent ils parlent franchement
mais il se fait attaquer pour avoir une
logique qui n'est pas québécois autre
chose mais si tu vois par exemple trous
d'eau et sa femme ensemble c'est fait ça
fait vraiment quelqu un couple qui sont
amoureux avec des royals à damas mais un
probable qu'aucun des politiciens à
faire des petits bisous bébé mais ça
démontre jusqu'à quel point
enraciné dans le québec et il devrait
démontrer qu'il était fasciné dans
québec et monsieur paquet on a vu les
chiffres
au québec le dernier débat en tout cas
en français pour monsieur duceppe
elle l'a montré à plus de monde parce
qu'il se tiendrait en par un peu plus
incognito jusqu'à jouer c'est sûr que
c'est une campagne aux moyens que le
bloc a présentement malgré tout une
campagne je pense qui est excellente
monsieur duceppe a fait plusieurs fois
le tour du québec ait rencontré
énormément de personnes mais là ça lui
donnait la possibilité de parler à plus
de monde en même temps et ce sera la
même chose ce soir et je pense que c'est
un des éléments qui explique la remontée
du bloc
il ya évidemment je pense les erreurs
que le npd a fait donc ce soit sur le
niqab la question d'équilibré budgétaire
comme le disait madame coach moi je
pense que ça c'est le npd s'est fait
doubler sur sa gauche et saluant nuit
énormément au québec parce que si on
regarde juste la question du niqab
les libéraux sont moins affectées que le
npd par cette question ne sont que plus
que ça et en trop je pense que la
question de l'équilibré budgétaire
déboussolé pas mal de monde et aussi on
apprend certaines choses qu'on savait
nous concernant le passé de monsieur
mulcair que ce soit comme procureur
alliance québec ou encore ces
déclarations alors qu'ils étaient
ménagés les mesures libérales avec jean
charest dans quelle mesure je vous
entendre les quatre là dessus dans
quelle mesure la personnalité d'ailleurs
du chef vraiment un facteur
incontournable dans une campagne
électorale puis les gens peuvent à tort
ou à raison développer une méfiance ou
plutôt une sympathie dépendant de
l'attitude du chef monsieur blackburn
je crois effectivement que ça joue ça
aussi parce que bon si je prends
l'exemple de monsieur harper où il est
très direct les questions de leader il
est calme
alors il semble toujours est en écoute
les autres façons intervent son
intervention a hobo au bon moment
devrais je dire
et en même temps bon vous avez en
traversant les deux orientations qui se
démarque un monsieur harper qui tient
absolument à avoir un budget équilibré
il dit je veux pas augmenter les taxes
et impôts et là vous avez monsieur
trudeau qui maintenant
dire non faut aller en 2008 monsieur
blackburn il ya monté l'epic a dit ça
c'est vrai qu'il a montée mais je pense
que ce soir avec le débat ça risque
peut-être de se re préciser cette
dimension là et on peut s'attendre que
monsieur harper vont peut-être tenté de
démontrer que si vous allez dans cette
orientation là c'est quoi les impacts
sur l'économie
c'est quoi les impacts sur la poche des
contribuables qu'est ce que ça va leur
coûter à la fin de l'année c'est cette
orientation alors qui de monsieur
trudeau se gardaient leur sort
l'envy du changement là on le sent moins
vous allez me dire le changement est
divisé en deux camps la saed pont non
mais aujourd'hui écoutés c'est la même
chose moi je me rappelles tu es
tranquille
le npd est à 30 2 les libéraux et les
conservateurs est alentours de 29
l'autre et hervé this toujours une
bataille à toi tout découle impeccable à
200 d'avertir c'est devenu une bataille
à 2 fuir c'est facile en directement aux
d'éliminer le npd comme monsieur paquet
parle de monsieur mulcair puis tout que
ce qui fait que monsieur mulcair à faire
avant moi je me rappelle en en 2010
j'ai eu du cep avait dit à la presse
canadienne pour l'exemple les gens qui
remplit pas la grande la langue formule
statistique canada on devrait il a
enlevé le passeport ou bien une coupe et
l'assurance chômage puis j'ai pas vu de
grands journalistes ou bien de médias
parler de ça ils étaient prêts à couper
l'assurance chômage aux gens qui
travaillent ils ont enlevé leur gagne
pain puis sa sortie c'était hugo un des
prix qu'il avait publiée dans la dans la
presse canadienne je veux dire écoutez
ce que l'on voit dans le procès de
monsieur le maire monsieur mulcair était
alors à le père plein aux auteurs quand
on regarde dans les sondages alors tous
les partis politiques qui étaient sur
lui
sais tu pues peur à la fin c'était juste
mulcair mulcair mais ça c'est le cas
maintenant je suis d'accord mais aussi
des nationales mais je connais je suis
le club vient nous dire que le npd à la
même âge auquel et quand ça va être un
souci de laisser des impôts des petites
entreprises pour le donner aux grosses
entreprises ont même champ clov la
pointure nantes au début c'était pas le
niqab c'était le moment où mais ce trou
d'eau est sorti en disant pour le moment
on a besoin d'investissements dans
l'infrastructure et moi je suis prête à
avoir des déficits pour trois ans de
déficit de la jirs pour trois ans pour
combler cette lacune dans la prochaine
ce sera vous le savez une solution
revient dans le temps messieurs mal car
elle dit non je m'arrange dernier sur un
peu et en ce moment là vous ai dit que j
étais je lui ai demandé vous êtes
innocent et c'est jusqu'à laisser le
terme il y joua la boue je connais je
suis le seul à terminer joue haley avoue
après je voulais juste dire que c'est le
moment je pense où la campagne a
commencé à changer et eelv on se
souvient au début la ces messieurs
mécanique qui ne voulait pas parler de
monsieur trudeau il
il a parlé juste de monsieur rare peut
il voulait même pas mentionné le tiers
parti comme on était à 25% ça valait
rien mais non que les tables sont
tournés c'est ce que c'est une lutte à
trois mais cette hausse est sûr que ce
soit la pression est sur mais sur mac
est en tout cas vu
monsieur je suis d'accord parce que
c'est que j'entends dire c'est que quand
que c'est qu'on regarde
qu'est ce que les libéraux vont faire
moi je me rappelle est d'encadrer
métrage je reviens là dessus il disait
il ya les coupes et la tps mais comme
j'étais à l'autre il a été obligé de
donner votre démission après ça fait des
libéraux fait des promesses phares
conseil défend pas jeudi qu'il comprend
pas l'assurance chômage mais ok mais là
les affaires difficiles tchèque aurait
mais vous avez jamais été d'ailleurs
encore que cette chose on parle de lutte
à trois dans le reste du canada où le
troisième et le npd
mais au québec actuellement c'est une
lutte à trois aussi est dépendant des
régions où en est ma carte dépendant des
régions et je pense que du rien de jouer
là au moment où on se bat qu'un le blog
se retrouvent à égalité avec les
conservateurs
pas très loin du npd alors le débat de
ce soir j'ai l'impression que monsieur
duceppe vouloir interpeller
monsieur mulcair en particulier sur les
grands enjeux qui préoccupent les
québécois et les québécoises à avoir des
réponses précises et la dernière fois la
dernier des bornes a pas eu de réponse
précise
alors on va revenir à la charge
j'imagine ce soir pour avoir des
réponses
cela ne répond pas se défilent les gens
auront la confirmation ce qui est là
aussi monsieur pas si méchant que ça
donne sur un peu là c'est pas tout à
fait la même situation que le vote
conservateur et concentrées
essentiellement dans la grande région de
québec
la viéle alors qu'il rêve s cube sera
plus rêve encore de plusieurs guerres au
québec
je me permets de rappeler à nouveau sur
ce que monsieur trudeau vu faire un
déficit de 30 milliards ça ça coûte à 2%
d'intérêt
ça coûte 600 millions d'intérêts par
année aux canadiens qui viennent menacer
nos programmes sociaux
6 et 4 % ça coûte 1,2 milliard par année
aux canadiens en intérêts c'est un coup
énorme et chacun va danser ce soir vos
vues je sens qu'on va lancer le plaisir
ce soir puis du côté de monsieur du
simple tiré son défi c'est pour de
profiter du fait que le npd est en
baisse pour dire aux gens mais revenez
donc vers ma formation politique mais ça
semble pas le cas présentement
j'ai regardé les sondages alors on est
30 % des francophones appuyé le bloc
actuellement on est en tête alors quand
on regarde la répartition des décomptes
et à travers le québec on a pas mal plus
de chance que les conservateurs de faire
élire des mois j'arrête dans un
gouvernement je crois encore que les
québécois va rentrer dans un
gouvernement
mais voilà alors de faire confiance aux
blocs on verra si ça fonctionne dans la
nbdl les sacs portant ce débat la haye
était important parce que les choses
bougent il reste un gros deux semaines à
la campagne électorale ça peut être long
deux semaines là mais moi je vais vous
l'avez mentionné au début ça allait deux
des trois dernières élections se sont
joués dans les deux dernières semaines
et ça va être le coach pense encore pour
l'élection du 9 octobre prochain
très bien vous allez oui un bon je vois
que dans les deux prochaines semaines on
va voir chacun des chefs aller dans les
circonscriptions où ils peuvent faire
des gains parce que bon c'est tellement
nez à nez que un deux trois cinq dix
députés de plus peut faire qu'un
gouvernement est au pouvoir de façon
majoritaire ou minoritaire mais ça
devient important députés par député
comté par comté
parce qu'on va s'entendre sur une chose
sur vous car vous êtes d'accord il n'y a
pas de vague l'on n'est pas dans le même
scénario 2011 0,5 par rapport à
l'opposition le sentiment de changement
ça peut créer une vague si bel et bien
le parti libéral à une équerre de 8%
avec les néo démocrates hayon à
l'élection dans deux semaines il va y
avoir une vague parce que le climat du
changement est très très grande et les
gens vont se ranger vers celle qui peut
former le gouvernement
on se retrouve on se reparle dans une
semaine ou vendredi prochain défi dans
ce vote fait sereine bondé bercy ce soir
cette semaine tout le monde